hello everyone my name is Sally I'm a
software engineer at Google here at Q
con Seattle and I have with me Dan
surelly nailed it
thank you I've been practicing that dan
you are product manager of Sto this is
correct and we have been talking to a
few folks about sto can you talk a
little bit about why is this to you
important why should someone care or why
should they use it well I think in
general people should be using Sto
because the the fact is people are
deploying applications now that are
complex and there's lots of
communication between pods between
clusters even and when there's
communication as part of your
application it's really important to be
able to understand what's communicating
with what control what's communicating
with what and secure all that so
applications are distributed now you
need a way to reason about that to
secure it in the control and sto
provides a nice way to do that it built
on top of kubernetes and you don't have
to have that logic hard-coded into every
single application that you write and
you can make modifications to add a
fleet level that's right I mean right
now typically people who either don't
secure their applications or they spend
a lot of developer time figuring out how
to do authentication and authorization
same thing goes for monitoring same
thing goes for traffic control and if
your developers are writing say
authentication code they're not writing
business code or if you're an insurance
company they're not writing insurance
app code right and so what we try to do
is just give more out-of-the-box so
developers can spend more of their time
writing services so it's the classic
separation of concerns design principle
being applied at a larger scale that's
exactly right
great so can you talk a little bit more
about what the current functionality is
in terms of the open source product yeah
so the three main things that people are
getting from SEO today are observability
which is just the ability to understand
how your application is working that
means gathering telemetry on every on
every call means gathering logs on every
call and traces
and putting those in a common place in
open source that might be Prometheus
some people are using it to send all the
information to date a dog we have an
open adapter that's sending it to
stackdriver
second big thing is control when a
service needs to call somewhere else
where is that service how do you find it
is there say a canary rollout going
right now
IE steel lets you control that and then
the last thing really is security
automatically putting MPLS on every
single call so that all of your data is
encrypted in transit and so that once
you have a strong identity for each call
you can perform authorization there's
three big benefits that they're getting
today that sounds awesome and what's
coming up next in terms of the
open-source side of things in terms of
open source we've got a big focus on
scalability and performance we've got
people who are running in production
today we also have people who are not
yet running in production because
they're too big people who are running
thousands of services much like
kubernetes in the early days SEO wasn't
ready for that so we've got a big
emphasis on on scalability and
performance a second big thing we're
working on is multi cluster lots of
people are running multiple clusters
today it might be that they're doing it
across different regions it might be
that they need for data locality reasons
and it might be because they're using
different cloud providers and/or data
centers but in all those cases they need
communication between those clusters and
so we are working hard to make it much
easier to simultaneously make calls from
cluster to cluster while maintaining
that observability gate security and
control got it so definitely a lot more
coming down the pipe I understand that
gke offers this do as a managed service
can you talk a little bit about that and
what GK adds to it so what we announced
today yesterday was sto on gke and what
that is it's an automated installation
and upgraded via steel components into a
AG ke cluster what that means is that
like some people have complained the
helm is relatively new people don't
really like it we said hey we'll do the
installation for you how people get
started
more importantly we do the upgrade for
you two upgrades are a pain one of the
things people love about gke
is that we upgrade your Alex for you
right we upgrade gke well if using is to
on gke we also update the SEO components
and so that that's a big benefit it's
gonna make it easier to get started
we also are by default sending all your
metrics all your logs and traces to
stackdriver so people can go create
really good service dashboards right the
the golden signals that is teo monitors
what is the the rate of traffic on each
service once the error rate
what are your latency is at different
percentiles lots of people don't know
that if you use this to ng ke you're
just gonna see that in stack traffic and
so what is your recommendation for
customers who might be interested in
adopting sto how do they get started
well I think this is the easiest way to
get started you know you know turn up a
gke cluster or take an existing one
install it one thing to note is that
that for sto some of the things that
does fairly transparently if you're just
using it for monitoring you don't have
to change the way you write your
application at all same thing is true
for M TLS if you want to get into more
sophisticated features if you want to
try doing canary rollouts say you're not
to understand the sto networking
concepts and you have to think about
those things but if what you really want
is just observability into your services
or just MPLS and your services you don't
have to change anything you install it
and it'll just start working that's
super cool all right let's switch gears
a little bit and we're here at Q Khan of
course this is the largest cube Khan
we've ever had I imagine this is not
your first cube Khan it's not can you
tell us a little bit about what the
changes that you've seen over time for
with the the various cube Khan's you've
attended and the community at large the
the this this is an amazing conference
I've been to a lot of conferences in my
day and and the sense of community here
and the energy is bizarre it really is
and and I'll tell you I've been a vendor
where we're on the show floor right now
right I've been at show floors where
tumbleweeds go blowing down the aisle
I'm not kidding because because it's not
worth going and here there are so
there's so much happening in this space
right now that everywhere you look there
are people having interesting
conversations and this isn't something
where all the vendors are just
travelling trying to you know get
someone to come listen to their sales
pitch it's where people
I'm here to learn right the sessions are
fantastic but everything that's going on
in this space is fantastic so of course
it's getting bigger I mean everyone must
say oh it's so much bigger of course
it's growing exponentially it seems like
yeah we were talking to Louis earlier
today and he mentioned that he hasn't
had a chance to attend any of the talks
because everybody's just so interested
in talking to him about its deal that
the thing is that all of the talks are
gonna be recorded you can how much all
that later what you can't do is go talk
to her and him and that person right
there later oh yes I think a lot of us
like I have been talking to people
non-stop today and I'll catch up on
sessions later that's awesome I mean
speaking of sessions is there anything
that you're interested in watching later
there there are a bunch of this T ough
sessions I'm gonna watch envoy also that
you know he was getting a lot of
attention part of that is because we
didn't chose to choose envoy and there
is so much happening the envoy space
just on its own and I'm certainly gonna
go back and catch some of that awesome
and last question what is your favorite
coupon memory memory that's a really
really tough one I'm gonna have to say
Kelsey hiked our keynotes oh yeah and
and it's hard to pick a particular one
because they're always amazing last year
he was a completely non-technical thing
Kelsey Hightower did his entrance three
times he came out he did his entrance
he's like what's happening that's not
enough
I'm gonna go back do that again and he
came out and of course then the crowds
really yelling that's not enough and the
third time people are practically on
their
it was a very Kelsey moment and and I
loved it
we loved Kelsey well thank you very much
Dan and enjoy the rest of you two blanks
on take care
[Music]